GILBERT STRANG: OK, ready
for part three of this vision
of linear algebra.
So the key word in part
three is orthogonal, which
again means perpendicular.
So we have
perpendicular vectors.
We can imagine those.
We have something called
orthogonal matrices.
That's when-- I've got one here.
An orthogonal matrix is
when we have these columns.
I'm always going
to use the letter
Q for an orthogonal matrix.
And I look at its
columns, and every column
is perpendicular to
every other column.
So I don't just have two
perpendicular vectors
going like this.
I have n of them because
I'm in n dimensions.
And you just imagine
xyz axes or xyzw axes,
go up to 4D for
relativity, go up to 8D
for string theory, 8 dimensions.
We just have vectors.
After all, it's just this row of
numbers or a column of numbers.
And we can decide when things
are perpendicular by that test.
Like say the test for Q1
to be perpendicular to Qn
is that row times that column.
When I say times, I mean dot
product, multiply every pair.
Q1 transpose Qn gives
that 0 up there.
So the columns
are perpendicular.
And those matrices are
the best to compute with.
And again, they're called Q.
And one way to, a
quick matrix way,
because there's always a matrix
way to explain something,
and you'll see how
quick it is here.
This business of
having columns that
are perpendicular to each
other, and actually, I'm
going to make those lengths of
all those column vectors all 1,
just to sort of normalize it.
Then all that's expressed by,
if I multiply Q transpose by Q,
I'm taking all
those dot products,
and I'm getting 1s when
it's Q against itself.
And I'm getting 0s when it's
one 1 Q versus another Q.
And again, just think of
three perpendicular axes.
Those directions
are the Q1, Q2, Q3.
OK?
So we really want to
compute with those.
Here's an example.
Well, that has just
two perpendicular axes.
I didn't have space
for the third one.
So do you see that those two
columns are perpendicular?
Again, what does that mean?
I take the dot product.
Minus 1 times 2, 2.
2 times minus 1,
another minus 2.
So I'm up to minus
4 at this point.
And then 2 times
2 gives a plus 4.
So it all washes out to 0.
And why is that 1/3 there?
Why is that?
That's so that these
vectors will have length 1.
There will be unit vectors.
Yeah, and how do I figure,
the length of a vector,
just while we're at it?
I take 1 squared or minus
1 squared gives me 1.
2 squared and 2 squared, I take
the dot product with itself.
So minus 1 squared,
2 squared, and 2
squared, that adds up to 9.
The square root of
9 is the length.
I'm just doing Pythagoras here.
There is one side of a triangle.
Here is a second
side of a triangle.
It's a right triangle
because that vector
is perpendicular to that one.
It's in 3D because they
have three components.
And I didn't write
a third direction.
And their length one
vectors because just that's
how when I compute the
length and remember
about the 1/3, which is put
in there to give a length 1.
So OK.
So these matrices are with
Q transpose times Q equal I.
That again, that's the
matrix shorthand for all
I've just said.
And those matrices are the
best because they don't
change the length of anything.
You don't have blow up.
You don't have going to 0.
You can multiply
together 1,000 matrices,
and you'll still have
another orthogonal matrix.
Yes, a little family
of beautiful matrices.
OK, and very, very useful.
OK, and there was
a good example.
Oh, I think the way
I got that example,
I just added a third row.
The third column, sorry.
The third column.
So 2 squared plus 2 squared
plus minus 1 squared.
That adds up to 9.
When I take the
square root, I get 3.
So that has length 3.
I divided by 3.
So it would have length 1.
We always want to see
1s, like we do there.
And if I-- here's a simple fact.
But great.
Then if I have two
of these matrices
or 50 of these matrices, I
could multiply them together.
And I would still
have length of 1.
I'd still have
orthogonal matrices.
1 times 1 times 1 forever is 1.
OK, so there's probably
something hiding here.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, to understand why
these matrices are important,
this one, this line is telling
me that, if I have a vector x,
and I multiply by Q, it
doesn't change the length.
This is a symbol
for length squared.
And that's equal to the
original length squared.
Length it is
preserved by these Qs.
Everything is preserved.
You're multiplying effectively
by the matrix versions
of 1 and minus 1.
And a rotation is a very
significant very valuable
orthogonal matrix, which
just has cosines and signs.
And everybody's remembering
that cosine squared plus sine
squared is 1 from trig.
So that's an orthogonal matrix.
Oh, it's also orthogonal
because the dot
product between that
one and that one,
you're OK for the dot product.
That product gives me minus sine
cosine, plus sine cosine, 0.
So the column 1 is
orthogonal to column 2.
That's good.
OK.
These lambdas that
you see here are
something called eigenvalues.
That's not allowed
until the next lecture.
OK, all right, now,
here's something.
Here's a computing thing.
If we have a bunch of columns,
not orthogonal, not length 1,
then, often, we would
like to convert them
to, so we call those, A1 to AN.
Nothing special
about those columns.
We would like to convert
them to orthogonal columns
because they're the
beautiful ones, Q1 up to Qn.
And two guys called Graham
and Schmidt figured out
a way to do that.
And a century later, we're
still using their idea.
Well, I don't know whose
idea it was actually.
I think Graham had the idea.
And I'm not really sure what
Schmidt, how he got into it.
Well, he may have
repeated the idea.
So OK, so I won't
go all the details.
But here's what the
point is the point
is, if I have a bunch of
columns that are independent,
they go in different
directions, but they're not
90 degree directions.
Then I can convert
it to a 90 degree one
to perpendicular
axes with a matrix R,
happens to be triangular, that
did the moving around, did
take that combinations.
So A equal QR is one of
the fundamental steps
of linear algebra and
computational linear algebra.
Very, very often,
we're given a matrix
A. We want a nice matrix Q, so
we do this Graham Schmidt step
to make the columns orthogonal.
And oh, here's a first
step of Graham Schmidt.
But you'll need practice
to see all the steps.
Maybe not.
OK, so here, what's
the advantage
of perpendicular vectors?
Suppose I have a triangle.
And one side is perpendicular
to the second side.
How does that help?
Well, that's a
right triangle then.
Side A perpendicular to side B.
And of course, Pythagoras, now
we're really going
back, Pythagoras said,
a squared plus b
squared is c squared.
So we have beautiful formulas
when things are perpendicular.
If the angles are not 90 degrees
when the cosine of 90 degrees
is 1 or maybe the sine
of 90 degrees is 1,
yeah, sine of 90 degrees is 1.
For those perfect
angles, 0 and 90 degrees,
we can do everything.
And here is a place that Q fits.
This is like the first big
application of linear algebra.
So let me just say what it is.
And it uses these cubes.
So what's the application
that's called least squares?
And you start with
equations, Ax equal b.
You always think
of that as a matrix
times the unknown
vector, being known,
right hand side b Ax equal b.
So suppose we have
too many equations.
That often happens.
If you take too
many measurements,
you want to get an exact x.
So you do more and
more measurements to b.
You're pasting more and
more conditions on x.
And you're not going to find
an exact x because you've
got too many equations.
m is bigger than n.
We might have
2,000 measurements,
say, from medical things
or from satellites.
And we might have
only two unknowns,
fitting a straight line
with only two variables.
So how am I going to solve
2,000 equations with two
unknowns Well, I'm not.
But I look for
the best solution.
How close can I come?
And that's what least
squares is about.
You get Ax as close
as possible to b.
And probably, this
will show how the--
yeah.
Yeah, here's the right equation.
When you-- here's my message.
When you can't solve Ax
equal b, multiply both sides
by A transpose.
Then you can solve
this equation.
That's the right equation.
So I put a little
hat on that x to show
that it doesn't solve the
original equation, Ax equal b,
but it comes the closest.
It's the closest
solution I could find.
And it's discovered by
multiplying both sides
by this A transpose matrix.
So A transpose A is a
terrifically important matrix.
It's a square matrix.
See, A didn't have to be square.
I could have lots of
measurements there,
many, many equations,
long, thin matrix for A.
But A transpose A always comes
out square and also symmetric.
And it's just a great
matrix for theory.
And this QR business
makes it work in practice.
Let me see if there's more.
So this is, oh, yeah.
This is the geometry.
So I start with a matrix A. It's
only got a few columns, maybe
even only two columns.
So its column space is just
a plane, not the whole space.
But my right hand side b is
somewhere else in whole space.
You see this situation.
I can only solve Ax
equal b when b is
a combination of the columns.
And here, it's not.
The measurements
weren't perfect.
I'm off somewhere.
So how do you deal with that?
Geometry tells you.
You can't deal with b.
You can't solve Ax equal b.
So you drop a perpendicular.
You find the closest
point, the projection that
in the space where
you can solve.
So then you solve Ax equal p.
That's what least squares is
all about, fitting the best
straight line,
the best parabola,
whatever, is all linear
algebra of perpendicular
things and orthogonal matrices.
OK, I think that's what I
can say about orthogonal.
Well, it'll come in again.
Orthogonal matrices,
perpendicular columns
is so beautiful, but next
is coming eigenvectors.
And that's another chapter.
So I'll stop here.
Good.
Thanks.